>>> TAKES ALL OF IT OUT THERE
FOR THE WORLD TO SEE.
AND MY NEXT GUEST IS CAITLYN
JENNER AND HER BOOK IS OUT NOW.
SECRETS OF MY LIFE.
YOU ARE COURAGEOUS.
>> I DID SAY THAT.
IT WAS ALMOST A NECESSITY.
I JUST GOT TO THE POINT IN MY
LIFE WHERE I GOT THAT MYSELF.
DESPITE THE POSSIBILITY OF
TREMENDOUS RIDICULE.
HAVING TO DEAL WITH THIS HIS
WHOLE LIFE.
AND PEOPLE WOULD LOOK AND GO, OH
MY GOD, THIS IS THE WEIRDEST
THING I'VE EVER SEEN.
>> I NEVER THOUGHT ABOUT IT.
AND I GREW UP WITH BROUS JENNER.
MY SISTER HAD THE BIGGEST CRUSH
ON YOU.
>> OH, I KNOW.
>> I HAVE PAID CLOSE ATTENTION
TO YOU FOR THE LAST TWO YEARS.
AND THIS BOOK -- I KNOW IT'S
BEEN TOUGH.
>> OH YEAH?
>> DAUNTING IN ALL OF THAT.
YOU'VE GOTTEN A LOT OF
CRITICISM, AND YOU'VE WEATHERED
IT.
WHAT THAT HAS BEEN LIKE?
>> YES.
>> FROM BEING MORE AMONG THE
CONSERVATIVE REPUBLICAN SIDE
THINGS THAT I HAVE SAID THAT I
DIDN'T WORD PROPERLY.
SUCH AS, YOU KNOW, MY SUPPORT
THE MARRIAGE EQUALITY ACT.
THIS AND THAT, WHICH I DO
SUPPORT.
I'VE OVER THE LAST TWO YEARS,
BUT I'VE TRIED TO LEARN FROM
THOSE MISTAKES.
I TRIED TO DO A BETTER JOB NEXT
TIME.
I LEARNED -- AND A LOT OF THE
CRITICISM HAS COME FROM WITHIN
MY COMMUNITY.
>> DO YOU THINK IT WAS A MISTAKE
TO VOTE FOR DONALD TRUMP?
>> NO.
NOT YET.
RIGHT NOW.
AS FAR AS LGBT ISSUES, YES, HE'S
MADE SOME MISTAKES.
OKAY.
BUT OTHER THINGS, I SEE, WE NEED
TO TURN THIS COUNTRY AROUND AND
HE'S A GUY THAT I THINK, FOR
BETTER OR WORSE, I DON'T SUPPORT
HIM IN EVERYTHING THAT HE DOES.
BUT WE NEEDED TO SHAKE THE
SYSTEM UP.
YOU KNOW, TO HAVE CAREER
POLITICIANS CON STRANTLY, THE
CLINTONS AND, YOU KNOW, THE
BUSHES RUN THIS COUNTRY, WE NEED
TO GET OUTSIDE THAT BOX AND
SHAKE THINGS UP AGAIN.
>> WHEN HE RESCINDED THE
TRANSGENDER STUDENTS.
YOU WILL A MESSAGE TO HIM.
LET'S LISTEN.
>> FINALLY AFTER I MESSAGE FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP, FROM, WELL, ONE
REPUBLICAN TO ANOTHER, THIS IS A
DISASTER.
AND YOU CAN STILL FIX IT.
YOU MADE A PROMISE TO PROTECT
THE LGBTQ COMMUNITY.
CALL ME.
>> SO A LOT OF PEOPLE IN THE
LGBT COMMUNITY SAW THAT AND
WHAT'D YOU EXPECT.
HE'S FLIP-FLOPPED ON A LOT.
THEY NEVER THOUGHT HE WAS GOING
TO PROTECT THEM.
>> LET ME TELL YOU, FIRST OF ALL
HE BROUGHT UP IT IN THE
INAUGURATION -- OR IN THE
CONVENTION, THE REPUBLICAN
CONVENTION.
HE BROUGHT IT UP.
HE HAS BEEN IN THE PAST
SUPPORTIVE OF LGBT ISSUES, THERE
WAS A GIRL NAMED JENNA, WHO WAS
A RAN ITS GIRL IN THE CANADIAN
MISS UNIVERSE PAGEANT WAY BEFORE
ALL OF THIS IN 2012.
HE SUPPORTED HER RIGHT TO BE
ABLE TO COMPETE IN THE MISS
UNIVERSE PAGEANT, REALLY STOOD
UP FOR THE TRANS GIRL, THAT'S A
GOOD THING.
OKAY.
IN OTHER INSTANCES HE HAS STOOD
UP FOR THE ENTIRE LGBT
COMMUNITY.
>> HE HASN'T NOW, WHAT DO YOU
DO?
>> WATCH HIM REALLY CLOSELY.
TO BE HONEST WITH YOU, THE
BOTTOM LINE IS, AS FAR AS TITLE
9 AND WHEN THAT WAS REPEALED,
I'M GOING WHY DO THIS?
THERE'S SO MANY OTHER IMPORTANT
ISSUES THAT THE PRESIDENT HAS TO
DEAL WITH.
WE HAVE SOUTH KOREA, WE HAVE
NORTH KOREA, AND WE HAVE ALL OF
THESE MESSES AND BORDER WALLS.
WE HAVE THIS AND THAT.
WHY DEAL WITH IT THIS?
IT'S NOT EVEN AN ISSUE.
>> LET'S TALK ABOUT THAT A
LITTLE BIT MORE.
I THOUGHT IT WAS INTERESTING.
AND YOU SAID THAT YOU ARE --
THAT YOU HAVE WEALTH, YOU'RE
ENTITLED, YOU'RE WHITE, AND YOU
WRITE THIS, THE ROLES HAVE MOST
DEFINITELY SWITCHED.
YOU TALK ABOUT ONCE YOU WERE
TRANSITIONED TO CAITLYN, AND ON
THE OUTSIDE, BRUCE ON THE
INSIDE, WHERE HE WILL HAPPILY
REMAIN FOR THE REST OF MY DAYS.
>> YES.
>> BRUCE WILL REMAIN ON THE
INSIDE, DO YOU THINK THAT YOU AS
BRUCE ARE SORT OF A PRIVILEGED,
YOU HAVE THE MINDSET OF A
PRIVILEGED, OLDER WHITE MAN AND
NOW YOU'RE ALL THE SUDDEN --
>> I NEVER -- HONESTLY IN MY
ENTIRE LIFE HAVE NEVER FELT
PRIVILEGED.
I WORK HARD.
I DIDN'T START OFF WITH
EVERYTHING.
I BUILT -- ANYTHING I HAVE, I
BUILT.
I USED TO LIVE IN -- I USED TO
LIVE ON $10,000 A YEAR UNTIL I
WAS 26 YEARS OF AGE.
>> YOU DON'T THINK IT'S --
>> $175 CAR.
>> I UNDERSTAND THAT, BUT
THAT'S -- A LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE
STRONG WORK ETHICS.
>> YEAH.
THAT WAS ME.
>> BUT IT'S HARDER FOR A RAN ITS
WOMAN WHO MAY NOT BE WHITE OR
WHO -- IT'S HARDER FOR A BLACK
FEMALE OR A BLACK MAN OR
HISPANIC MAN OR WOMAN,
ESPECIALLY A TRANS WOMEN TO BE
ABLE TO DO THAT.
>> TOTALLY AGREE.
AND HOW WOULD YOU AND I TEAM UP
TOGETHER AND MAKE IT BETTER FOR
THEM?
AND THAT'S WHAT I'M DOING.
>> I WOULD LOVE TO DO THAT
ACTUALLY.
>> I WOULD LOVE -- THAT'S MY
MISSION.
I'M FINE.
HONESTLY.
I AM FINE.
I'VE GOT A ROOF OVER MY HEAD.
I'VE GOT WONDERFUL CHILDREN.
I'VE GOT A VERY GOOD LIFE -- I
AM FINE.
>> BUT BACK -- YOU DON'T SEE
THAT AS A PRIVILEGE?
>> I WANT TO HELP THAT
MARGINALIZED COMMUNITY.
AND ESPECIALLY THE TRANS YOUTH
COMING UP.
THAT'S ALL I DO.
IS WORK ON THINGS LIKE THAT.
AND SO, MY LOYALTIES ARE NOT
WITH DONALD TRUMP, MY LOYALTIES
ARE NOT WITH THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY, MY LOYALTIES ARE NOT WITH
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
MY LOYALTIES WITH WITH MY
COMMUNITY AND I WANT TO MAKE IT
BETTER.
>> AS AN LGBT PERSON.
I DON'T THINK YOU SHOULD PUT
SOMEONE IN A BOX.
YOU SHOULDN'T EXPECT THEM TO BE
A DEMOCRAT OR TO BE LIBERAL.
RIGHT?
>> YEAH, AND WE HAVE
CONSERVATIVE REPUBLICANS LIKE
MYSELF.
A LOT OF THEM.
>> BUT YOU SAID YOU DIDN'T
TRANSITION TO BECOME A LIBERAL
DEMOCRAT.
>> RIGHT.
>> DO YOU THINK THAT SOMETIMES
WE TAKE THOSE TERMS, YOU KNOW,
WE TALK ABOUT ISSUES THAT HAS TO
DO WITH THE LGBT AND MAYBE IT'S
JUST SOME OF THOSE ISSUES ARE
NOT NECESSARILY BEING A LIBERAL
OR BEING A DEMOCRAT.
IT'S JUST BEING HUMANE OR HAVING
EMPATHY?
>> I AGREE.
I AGREE THAT, YES, I AGREE WITH
THAT.
I'M NOT INTO REALLY LABELS
EITHER.
>> YOU SAID SOMETHING AND I
THOUGHT -- YOU SAID THAT NO
QUESTION IS OFF-LIMITS, BUT YOU
THINK A QUESTION THAT'S HIGHLY
APPROPRIATE IS ABOUT THE FINAL
SURGERY FOR AN LGBT PERSON.
YOU ADMITTED THAT YOU DID.
WHY DID YOU FEEL --
>> DID I SAY THAT?
>> YES, YOU DID.
>> OKAY.
>> WHY DID YOU FEEL THE NEED
SHARE WITH THE WORLD?
BECAUSE YOU SAID IT'S
INAPPROPRIATE.
>> BECAUSE THE BOOK IS ABOUT
HONESTY.
AND I AM -- I TELL THINGS IN
THAT BOOK THAT I NEVER THOUGHT I
WOULD TELL ANYBODY IN THE WORLD
ABOUT IT.
YOU KNOW, AND I HAD TO BE
EXTREMELY HONEST.
I TALK ABOUT A LITTLE BIT
DURING -- THROUGH THE BOOK, I
DRAW INTO REASONS TO WHY I CAME
TO THAT DECISION.
THAT'S IN THE BOOK, BUT AS FAR
AS THE FINAL SURGERY, IT'S
REALLY NOT SOMETHING THAT I --
IT'S EXTRAORDINARILY PERSONAL.
IT'S NOT SOMETHING ANY
TRANCE PERSON WANTS TO TALK
ABOUT.
TO BE HONEST, MOST RAN ITS WOMEN
DO NOT HAVE THAT SURGERY DONE.
THEY'RE HAPPY WITH THE WAY THEY
ARE.
OKAY.
AND THEY DON'T HAVE IT DONE.
PLUS IT'S EXPENSIVE, IT'S TOUGH
TO DO AND ALL THAT KIND OF
STUFF.
AND SO I DON'T TO WANT
DISRESPECT THEM.
SPAEBLFULLY THEY DON'T TO WANT
GO THROUGH FINAL SURGERY, THAT'S
FINE.
JUST LIVE YOUR LIFE.
DOESN'T MAKE ANY DIFFERENCE.
I WAS NO MORE A WOMAN THE DAY
BEFORE I HAD THE SURGERY THAN I
WAS THE DAY AFTER THE SURGERY.
IT'S JUST -- THE PUBLIC'S
PERCEPTION IS THEY THINK THAT
THAT'S WHAT IT'S ALL ABOUT.
AND IT IS NOT ABOUT THAT.
IT'S ABOUT MY SOUL.
>> AND YOU'RE VERY CLEAR.
YOU SAID, I AM A TRANCE WOMAN, I
CAN'T GIVE BIRTH
I COULDN'T, AS A REPUBLICAN
WHO'S WANTING BETTER
UNDERSTANDING COULD NOT HAVE A
BETTER SILVER BULL TOOT TALK TO
MOSTLY WHITE, MOSTLY OLDER, A
LOT OF MEN ABOUT BEING
TRANSGENDER.
I CAN'T DELIVER THAT MESSAGE BUT
THERE'S NO BETTER MESSENGER THAN
CAITLYN JENNER.
YOU SHOULD SEE HER IN THESE
MEETINGS.
BUT SHE IS EXTRAORDINARY BECAUSE
SHE IS SHARING A REALLY
AUTHENTIC PERSONAL EXPERIENCE TO
SOMEONE WHO'VE NEVER SEEN A
TRANSPERSON BEFORE.
>> ARE THEY TOUGH CONVERSATIONS?
>> ONE WAS WITH A LOT OF
BASICALLY EVANGELICAL
CHRISTIANS, CONSERVATIVE
SENATORS AND CONGRESSMAN.
BECAUSE THEY KNEW MY STORY AND
WHO I WAS, THEY INVITED ME TO A
VERY PRIVATE DINNER AND WE HAD A
CONVERSATION ABOUT FAITH AND
TRANSITIONING AND THE ISSUES
THAT CONCERN TRANSPEOPLE AND IT
IT JUST OPENED UP THE
CONVERSATION TO WHERE AT THE
END, ONE OF THEM IN THE BACK
SAYS WHEN WE GET TO POLICY, DO
YOU THINK WE CAN CALL YOU?
AND I'M THINKING YOU MIGHT BE
ABLE TO, YEAH.
>> HAVE YOU GOTTEN ANY CALLS
FROM THE ADMINISTRATION?
>> I ORIGINALLY TALKED TO AT
THAT TIME, TRUMP, ON THE PHONE.
BUT NO, I HAVEN'T GOTTEN.
THE ONLY -- I HAVE REACHED OUT
TO A SENATOR AND WE HAVE TALKED
SINCE THEN ON ISSUES AND HE WAS
ABSOLUTELY GREAT AND THAT
CONVERSATION NEVER WOULD HAVE
HAPPENED IF IT WASN'T FOR THAT
MEETING, THAT DINNER WE HAD.
>> WOULD YOU LIKE TO MEET WITH
THE PRESIDENT?
>> WELL --
>> I HAVE.
HE WANTS ME TO PLAY GOLF WITH
HIM.
>> WE TALK ABOUT ROLLING BACK
SOME OF THE PROTECTIONS.
>> AND THAT KIND OF KILLED IT
FOR ME.
I CAN'T.
I JUST CAN'T.
HE WANTED TO PLAY GOLF.
I WOULD LOVE TO GO DOWN, EVEN
AFTER THE FACT THAT HE TOOK THIS
TITLE NINE THING AWAY, I WOULD
LOVE TO PLAY GOLF WITH HIM AND
SAY WHY THE HELL DID YOU DO
THAT?
THAT WAS THE STUPIDEST THING
I'VE EVER SEEN AND TELL HIM THAT
BUT NOW I CAN'T BECAUSE IF I WAS
PUBLICLY SEEN WITH HIM, I WOULD
BE U.S.A. RUICIZED FROM THE
COMMUNITY.
I WOULD LIKE THE HAVE THAT
MEETING SBRUT IT PRIVATELY.
>> WOULD YOU THINK ABOUT HAVEING
IT WITH MEMBERS OF THE
COMMUNITY?
DO YOU THINK HE WOULD BE OPEN TO
THAT?
>> IF I SET IT UP, YEAH.
AL I EVEN HAD CONVERSATION WITH
MIKE PENCE AND WHEN HE WAS
GOVERNOR CAME UP WITH THE MOST
ANTILGBT ISSUES AND LEGISLATION.
HE NEEDS A TALKING TO.
JEFF SESSIONS NEEDS A TALKING TO
BUT AS FAR AS OTHER THINGS, I'M
NOT A ONE ISSUE VOTER.
THERE'S MORE TO IT THAN JUST
TR
TRANS ISSUES.
>> CAITLYN, BECAUSE SHE'S A
REPUBLICAN, THEY BELIEVE THEY'RE
TALKING TO ONE OF THEM AND THEY
ARE.
I MEAN, SHE IS AUTHENTIC AND SO
IT'S NOT AN ORGANIZATION THAT
HAS ALWAYS -- IT'S
ANTIREPUBLICANS GOING TO TRY TO
TALK ABOUT WHAT THE ISSUES ARE
FACING THE TRANSCOMMUNITY AND
TALKING ABOUT KIDS, TRANSKIDS,
THE SUICIDE RATE, THE HATE
CRIMES WHICH ARE PREVALENT AND
RAMPANT.
AND REALLY MAKING AN AUTHENTIC
CASE.
THEY CAN HEAR IT FROM HER
BECAUSE THEY SO THEY HAVE A
POLITICAL WORLD VIEW IN COMMON,
AN IDEOLOGY IN COMMON, A FAITH
IN COMMON.
AND SO SHE'S ABLE TO CROSS ALL
THESE BARRIERS THAT EVEN I CAN'T
CROSS.
>> BUT MARGARET, YOU UNDERSTAND,
FOR A TRANS-WOMAN, MAY NOT HAVE
THE LUXURY TO VOTE ON OTHER
ISSUES, IT MAY JUST BE AN ONE
ISSUE VOTER BECAUSE IT'S ABOUT
LIFE AND DEATH AND GETTING A JOB
FOR HER AND THEY CAN'T
UNDERSTAND --
>> THE REALITY OF OUR GOVERNMENT
RIGHT NOW, WHETHER YOU LIKE IT
OR NOT AND THIS IS WHAT IS
REALLY DIFFICULT FOR THE LGBT
COMMUNITY TO WRAP THEIR HEAD
AROUND.
YOU HAVE A REPUBLICAN SENATE, A
REPUBLICAN HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES.
THAT'S JUST AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL.
THEN YOU TAKE ALL THE GOVERNORS.
2/3 OF THEM ARE ALL REPUBLICANS.
IF YOU'RE NOT ENGAGING
REPUBLICAN LEGISLATURES, YOU'RE
NOT ADVOCATING FOR CHANGES THAT
WILL LEAD TO LGBT COMMUNITY.
>> I COULDN'T HAVE SAID IT
BETTER.
>> WOULD YOU EVER RUN FOR
OFFICE?
>> AT FIRST I THOUGHT I WOULD
NEVER RUN FOR OFFICE.
WHY?
BECAUSE I GOT WAY TOO MANY
SECRETS.
BECAUSE I'VE TALKED TO
REPUBLICAN GROUPS AND THEY GO
AFTER YOUR SPEECH AND THIS AND
THAT.
GOD, YOU SHOULD RUN FOR OFFICE.
NOW I HAVE NO MORE SECRETS.
THEY'RE ALL OUT.
I GOT NOTHING.
THE MEDIA COULDN'T GO CRAZY.
>> SO ANSWER MY QUESTION.
>> I WOULD HAVE TO LOOK OVER THE
NEXT YEAR OR TWO AND SEE CAN I
DO A BETTER JOB ON THE OUTSIDE
OR AM I IN A POSITION I CAN DO A
BETTER JOB ON THE INSIDE.
IF I FIND IT'S ON THE INSIDE, I
WOULD SERIOUSLY LOOK AT IT.
>> BE THE VOICE OF THE
VOICELESS.
YOU HAVE A HUGE PLATFORM.
AS LONG AS YOU DO THAT,T,